hello everyone and welcome to a new
video today we're going to be discussing
the story of resident evil village and
what exactly transpired during our time
there first of this video will be broken
up into three parts
the first will be a recap of the
resident evil 7 story
re7 came out around 4 years ago and
while some may still remember the story
many
may not so that will serve as a quick
refresher this will include the events
of the story as well as the dlc related
to the game's main narrative that being
the not a hero end of zoe and daughters
dlc
after that is the resident evil village
story recap then finishing off the video
with a discussion about the ending of
the game what that means for the rest of
the story as well as the game's life
span going forward feel free to jump to
any part that you like but without
further ado like it subscribe if you
enjoy and let's get started so our
protagonist is ethan winters a newcomer
in the series being only featured in the
past two games
he receives a message at the beginning
of the game from his wife and it's an
update on her job
until the next message which seems more
dark and grim she tells ethan not to
look for her and surprisingly unlike
many horror protagonists he actually
listens except for three years later he
receives another message that tells him
to visit the baker estate the baker
estate is home to four people
lucas jack marguerite and zoe baker but
the baker family and mia as well seem to
be infected with some sort of virus for
some much needed
context mia lied to ethan about her
occupation she actually works for the
connections a criminal syndicate
dedicated to money laundering
drug trafficking but more importantly
biochemical research the connections
were researching and developing a bio
weapon called the e series e-series
0-0-1 or
evelyn evelyn has supernatural powers
and was supposed to be kept stable and
under control as the connections were
transporting her via a ship
a hurricane hit the boat and evelyn
freaked out which caused her to create
this black substance known as the mold
when enough mold comes together they
can create the molded enemies we see
throughout the game eventually the ship
was torn apart and mia evelyn and the
ship were washed ashore near the baker
estate the bakers being the loving and
healthy family that they are
not only cared for mia but also evelyn
but they didn't understand what evelyn
was
they just assumed she was a little girl
evelyn sees the opportunity to infect
the entire family
starting with marguerite then to jack
lucas and zoe are also infected but they
aren't as far gone as their parents they
both have regenerative abilities which
is a side effect of the mold but both
parents are under the mind control of
evelyn whereas zoe and lucas aren't the
connections eventually discovered
evelyn's new location so they set up a
base near assault mine not too far from
the house they also hired lucas as a
researcher so they could monitor evelyn
from afar leading up to evelyn's arrival
from 2014 to 2017 lucas would work with
the connections and inevitably kill all
the researchers to harness the mold for
himself and the bakers would end up
kidnapping people under evelyn's control
so she can have a much bigger family one
of these people she attempted to kidnap
was ethan as evelyn compelled mia into
sending the original message to him so
as ethan and we must find mia and escape
things definitely don't go that simple
as we have boss fights with both jack
and marguerite we end up getting trapped
in lucas's mini-games all while fighting
the molded that was created since
evelyn's arrival we also find out that
neither zone or mia can leave the house
without the serum to cure them we only
have enough for one as we ended up using
the other to kill jack
we save mia as that's the canon ending
and as we approach the wreckage evelyn
flips our raft evelyn captures ethan and
mold and while he's captured we enter a
sort of dream state in which we discover
that the baker family isn't the bad
people we see in game they're clearly
under the influence of evelyn so none of
this is their fault and they're victims
just like us
after being saved by mia we discovered
the location of the salt mine and
discover tons of information that we
previously discussed and the lab is the
equipment we need for the serum we then
find evelyn and inject the serum inter
she materializes then becomes a very big
infected monster like jack was during
the fight a helicopter comes by and
drops us a weapon that is able to kill
her very quickly this helicopter happens
to also be owned by a blue umbrella and
the iconic chris redfield
blue umbrella is not the normal umbrella
they still have the same name so the
public notices that they're taking
responsibility for their past actions
and cleaning up the biological messes
they
made chris redfield for ages has been
employed by the bsaa
never umbrella but since it's a new
version of umbrella the two have a
common goal which is why he was sent to
the baker estate with them the original
mission was actually to apprehend lucas
the part with evelyn was an unexpected
welcome
after the conversation with chris and
ethan we as chris attempt to capture
lucas and once he's cornered he also
mutates like evelyn and jack chris
easily takes him down and blue umbrella
sets up an exclusion zone to prevent the
mold from going outside the property
weeks later
joe baker arrives so that he can rescue
zoe thanks to ethan making her a promise
and most of the dlc really isn't too
relevant but
joe helps cure zoe and defeat jack once
more hopefully this time for good so a
quick recap on where our cast is
ethan and mia are safe but possibly
still under the watch of blue umbrella
due to them still being infected with
the mould chris is working with blue
umbrella under bioterrorism assignments
and the baker family is dead besides joe
and zoe we now continue our story in
resident evil village
so with the release of re8 we also got
an incident report on the events between
both games and what transpired it's
about 80 different documents but to
summarize some of the more interesting
bits
this entire report seems to be written
by zoe baker she also managed to find
herself a job as a rookie reporter
after the incident at the house we also
found out that oswald spencer's
colleague brandon bailey is the leader
of the connections also further
explaining that the connections don't
want to take over the world rather just
pride off bioweapons like with evelyn
and re7
oswald spencer for those who don't
remember is the founder and ceo of
umbrella we see him appear in re5 with
albert wesker
after our journey through the baker
estate mia and ethan were under the
supervision of the bsaa and were moved
to europe
zoe was also under their custody and was
released shortly after
the bsa during this time tried to cover
up the story as an accidental gas leak
so the press wouldn't freak out
later in the notes we also find out that
chris took control of the bsaa hound
wolf squad without their permission and
has been looking into a ton of personal
files related to the winters and mother
miranda the bsaa found out and sent him
a message about this to which he only
replied
it's not over so now that we've actually
made it to resident evil 8 let's discuss
the intro and how ethan got to the
village then jump back to what actually
happened
we see mia and ethan next to their new
daughter rosemary winters
as the couple are sitting together they
are talking and getting into a slight
argument about mia's memories
it seems like she wants to forget
everything that happened at the baker
house and honestly i would too
ethan puts rose to bed and the two
decide to have a nice dinner together
until chris and his squad members shoot
mia as the bullets stop
ethan rises to see chris he then takes
rose and we get knocked out
ethan wakes up to see the truck
destroyed and rose is gone
we then make it to the village and get
introduced to the town's residence and
wildlife
while on our way through the village we
also meet an older lady who is quite
unsettling we meet more of the villagers
and see that the lycans we're facing can
just transform seemingly at random as
elena's father is infected and tears
through the other villagers
after gaining access to the castle a man
named heisenberg captures us and we meet
the four lords of the village and the
leader herself
mother miranda ethan's current objective
is to find his daughter rose who might
be in the castle which is why we end up
here in the first place
in usual resident evil fashion towards
the ending of the game we get loads of
info on the actual story
so the reason chris is even here
investigating all this to begin with is
that they found that the dna of the muta
my seat or the mold from re7 is about
99.95
similar to the same dna at this village
it's also assumed that the village is
where the mold originated from
from now on any time i say the word mudo
my seat i'm talking about the mold it's
just a lot easier to say for the viewer
to understand just in case you're
confused the colony of the mold seems to
be spreading across the whole village
the mold is kind of like a network and
the baker estate was just one strand of
its long connection of data
chris obviously being chris wants to
stop the infection and if he can blow it
up at the source then he's going to do
that which is where this report led to
the reason chris killed mia in the intro
is because that's mother miranda the
next question would be how is that
possible
mother miranda isn't mia this isn't some
she was the bad guy all along plot twist
we know this cause mia and chris see
each other and he confirms it for
himself miranda has the ability that
chris calls mimicry she can control
and change her cells to become anyone
she wants she was not only mia but also
that old lady throughout the game
this explains why mia forgot her
memories in the intro she didn't forget
or try to suppress them
miranda doesn't know everything about
the baker incident because she wasn't
there
mother miranda was alive during the
spanish flu which is around 1918.
during this time her daughter eva died
from the disease miranda was so ridden
with grief that she went into a cave to
just sit there and hope she died along
with her daughter that's when she
discovered the mega my seat the
mood of micey is just the mold the mega
micey is the origin of the mold where
everything started the mega my seed
according to her breaks down and absorbs
the consciousness of those who have died
meaning that there is possibly a way to
bring her daughter back to do this
however she needed a vessel for her
daughter's consciousness
she tested out the mold from the mega my
seat on the villagers nearby
and nothing was really working so she
ended up creating a parasite called the
cadao to help make the testing more
efficient but once again nothing was
working there were only four people who
successfully bonded with the cadal
parasite those four
being the four house lords while miranda
was experimenting with the mold and
organization
contacted her which was the connections
they borrowed some of miranda's mold to
make evelyn which is how she heard of
mia and ethan and then to rose
seeing as the spanish flu is around 100
years old we can obviously see that the
mold gave her him mortality or at least
the ability to not die of old age
the whole thing about the chopped up
body parts is explained as well as she
wanted to test rose's regenerative
abilities using the regulator
the regulator is the thing we put the
flasks in and that's connected to the
mega mice down underneath the surface
which is why she's still alive even
after being cut
up may have noticed an interesting
symbol on the regulator however
this is explained in another note where
a student of miranda sent her a letter
detailing some of his new ideas that
student is
oswald spencer which we just mentioned
earlier was the founder of umbrella he
got the inspiration for the name and the
symbol of the company from the logo
at that village oswald visited the
village miranda was at which kickstarted
the whole umbrella development he was
amazed at the ability to transform a
human using another organism oswald's
original idea was to pave the way for
the next step in human evolution
miranda only wanted to do this though to
save her daughter which is why oswald
ultimately decided to leave the village
as her experiments weren't helping his
goals
only hers so miranda is this 100
something year old woman trying to bring
back her dead daughter by finding the
proper vessel for her consciousness
i won't go too in depth on the lords as
their abilities and backstory are
mentioned quite a bit through the
various notes but like i stated mother
miranda tested the cadao on the
villagers and only four people were able
to bond with it without turning into a
lycan those four of course being are
four house
lords each one ruled a different section
of the village and mostly kept to
themselves
lady demontresque owned the demetres
castle which had an all-woman staff
where any servant who didn't do a good
job was subjected to torture and death
so they could become wine for her and
her daughters
she also infected the three witches
which she then later of course called
her daughters who also have supernatural
abilities and a weakness to cold
temperatures
not much is known about moreau and donna
but the two also seem to have their own
sections of the village and are secluded
to themselves donna has an affinity for
doll since this was the last gift her
father gave her before she died and miro
got the short end of the cadao stick
since he is clearly the most mutated out
of the four
and has the ability to transform into a
giant fish which he cannot control
this lack of power caused him to feel
hated by the others so he shut himself
away heisenberg is the unique one of the
group as he is arguably the smartest and
strongest of the four
he owns the nearby factory and
underneath has created an entire robot
army the purpose for this is because he
wants revenge for what miranda did to
him
he seems to be the only one of the four
who holds a grudge against her so he's
been secretly plotting a rebellion
against miranda so that she can pay for
cursing him with his power
that power being the ability to
manipulate magnetic fields and control
electricity after defeating heisenberg
we meet with mother miranda and she rips
ethan's heart out
as we're left stunned by what just
happened we hear chris give us a quick
recap about our time
in the village he explains that mother
miranda was mia and that even though she
looked dead she was only faking it she
was also the cause of the crash at the
beginning of the game
chris after ethan's fight with
heisenberg went to find him but he was
already dead
we now get to play as chris and take her
down after going through the large info
dump laboratory we find mia
actually mia this time not mother
miranda like we stated
chris gives her the news that ethan is
dead but she explains that that's
impossible and that he needs to find him
because he's very special
ethan out of nowhere wakes up and we
hear a familiar voice
evelyn has returned somehow even though
we killed her back at the baker house
evelyn and ethan talk with each other
and we uncover probably the biggest
twist in the whole game
evelyn explains that when we got knocked
out by jack back in re7
he actually killed us we didn't wake up
and survive and eat at the dinner table
we died there this explains how ethan is
able to literally attach his arm back
into place like it's nothing it's not
just the first aid meds that are helping
it's the mold in his body this isn't one
of those weird situations where he's
slightly infected and has those regen
abilities like the others do his entire
body is
literal mold as we can see now when even
later in the game
we see that his hand is becoming
calcified as ethan collapses the duke
picks us up and drops us off near mother
miranda so that we can kill her we do
get a bit of slight help from chris but
it's mostly just 1v1 against her in
typical resident evil fashion once again
she does
transform into some hideous creature as
ethan kills mother miranda chris grabs
both him and rows and escorts them to
safety chris has a plan to blow the
whole mega my seat up along with the
whole village
ethan already knowing he's close to
death though gives chris rose in his
jacket
takes the detonator and finishes the job
himself what a
crazy ending that was now that the
ending is over though what exactly is
next for the resident evil story
well we're most likely going to be
getting dlc in an eventual ninth main
title in the series so there's tons more
for us to explore in the world
but what are we doing and where are we
going well back at the helicopter a
member of chris's squad shows us one of
the bsaa members we spotted during the
intro to chris's sequence they seem to
be infected with something as they
aren't human
chris tells the pilot to head for the
bsa hq in europe as someone has some
explaining to do in the concept art for
the bsaa members we read the description
that says the bsaa are now a raw and
ruin organization who are using soldiers
created with new technology so it seems
like the bsa
are going to be put in some hot water in
the next part of the story whether
that's dlc
or a full new game my guess is we'll
probably go back to chris for some time
or we might see another protagonist
that new one could end up being rose as
an end credit scene does show us
a grown-up rose probably around 20 30
visiting ethan's grave we can see that
the bsa are keeping a close eye on her
since as we discover thanks to the
infected mold from both ethan and mia
she now has power similar to
if not better than evelyn this is a plot
device i cannot
wait to see unfold with that however we
do come to the end of the video
and the end of resident evil village for
now at least
let me know in the comments below how
you enjoyed the video as well as the
game itself as someone who's recently
gotten to resident evil a lot more with
the release of re7 it sucks to see ethan
go like this but i have no issue playing
as chris again he's a staple of the
franchise and for good reason
he's an excellent protagonist with that
however though like the video if you do
enjoy subscribe if you're new and
take care everybody goodbye
[Music]
you